-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How is everybody doing tonight
Glad to hear it.
Let's get to the news.
President Trump and
former vice president Joe Bide
faced off in their
second and final debate,
moderated by NBC News
White House correspondent
Kristen Welker
or, just as likely,
between President Trump
and Kristen Welker
and moderated by Joe Biden
"Alright, come on, guys."
That's right --
the last presidential debate
was held tonight.
Now, we filmed this
before the debate,
so we don't know what happened
We don't even know if
it happened.
Maybe Trump walked out
15 minutes after it started,
and now he's promising to
release the unaired footag
of the rest of the debate.
Maybe it was canceled becaus
he tested positive for rickets
Truly, anything could be o
the table, including Trump
Ahead of tonight's
final presidential debate,
organizers instituted
a rule change
allowing for the candidates'
microphones to be muted.
So I'm guessing President Trum
spent the whole evening
interrupting Joe Biden
by semaphore.
In a "Washington Post" op-ed
published earlier this week,
a member of the Commission o
Presidential Debates
said that President Trump'
attacks on his organization ar
"Just wrong."
And even in "The Post,"
Trump was able to interrupt.
According to a new poll,
56% of voters
do not believe that
President Trump
deserves a second term.
Unfortunately, the other
44% want him to have a fourth.
During a campaign appearance
on Monday,
President Trump's daughter and
White House advisor Ivanka Trump
said she's teaching hersel
how to play guitar
during the coronavirus pandemic.
And, somehow,
her guitar is still only
the second-worst thing
she could bring to a party
"Don't go in the kitchen.
Yeah, she took out Jared."
Finally, the short-form
streaming service Quibi
announced yesterday
that it's shutting down
after only six months.
So I guess let's go ahead
and make it official.
And that was a monologue.